there's a very interesting article in
salon by Amanda Marcotte about what we
are about to see Republicans do
Republicans that who are right as we
speak
coming to power taking control of the
house and I guess selecting a speaker of
the house although it's been harder to
actually get that done the article is
called the GOP is about to go wild with
phony Biden investigations the media
must not take the bait Republicans know
how to manipulate the both sides impult
of the press Hunter Biden's laptop is
not a story writes Amanda Marcotte this
is an important
um uh admonishment that I hope is being
made in corporate media newsrooms around
the country although I fear that it is
not
the both sides narrative is a toxic form
of false equivalence that has
unfortunately become really common in
corporate media and there's a couple of
reasons why and this is the idea that
all political viewpoints are equally
valid and deserve to be heard regardless
of their factual basis regardless of
their uh connection to reality it's
intellectually lazy it undermines
critical thinking it undermines rational
discourse and those are elements that
are essential to a functioning democracy
why does corporate media do this why
does corporate media have to use one
example
one person who says here's the climate
science and one person who just denies
it it's 50 50 on your screen I mean look
I see this talking head saying here's
the climate science and I see this
talking head saying you can't believe
any of that stuff they're getting 50 50
representation even though in the
empirical Community one side has more
than 99 agreement of the scientific
Community behind them why does corporate
media do that there's two main reasons
number one
they do it because they want to avoid
being called biased
to some degree they say well listen it's
controversial so let's represent these
two things 50 50 even if in reality they
are not 50 50. that's one reason the
other is for Ratings it's much more
interesting to do these debates where
you actually foment the belief
in things for which there is no factual
basis when the media fall for this trap
they give credibility to lies and
misinformation and they perpetuate those
ideas they perpetuate also the idea that
there's not really an objective Truth
Listen let's have a debate as to what
the tax rate should be okay well that's
a debate there are moral questions
economic questions fairness questions
governance questions fine let's have a
debate as to whether climate change is
real
totally different thing irresponsible uh
and and by the way I'm fine with
discussions among people who disagree
about the climate science I think that
that's fine the problem is that
corporate media that does 39 minutes of
content per hour or less the rest is
commercials and hosts four minute
debates where half the debate is a
climate science denier that's a
different thing that we're talking about
and it's especially dangerous in the
current political climate where we see
the rise in authoritarianism we see a
decline in trust in institutions it's
important for the media to hold
politicians accountable it's important
for the media to hold public figures and
so-called experts accountable for their
words and their actions but you've got
to do so in a way that at least somewhat
aligns with reality it doesn't mean you
give equal weight and time
to baseless conspiracy theories and
propaganda and that's where we get to
Joe Biden the Biden crime family 100
essential I accidentally hit the truth
Central button because I'm so so wound
up what we what we have to see here is a
recognition that the hunter Biden
conspiracy theory is the prototypical
example of how the both sides narrative
can end up just being so destructive
it's been thoroughly debunked it's been
fact-checked they insist on baseless
elements of Hunter Biden's background at
some point the media has a
responsibility to report what the facts
are not to promote baseless conspiracy
theories to give equal weight to lies in
propaganda to host false debates which
is what they are at the end of the day
and
to the extent that Republicans are going
to be obsessing for two years about
impeach Biden for these crimes those
crimes Hunter Biden this that the other
thing
if corporate media is going to cover
that they should just be clear there's
no credible evidence to support the
things that people like Marjorie Taylor
green want to investigate about Joe and
Hunter Biden will they do it probably
not